que je l'ai regardé je l'ai pas quitté
des yeux
je lui en sais presque un défi
du genre que c'est moi qui ai été c'est
pas le contraire
et il m'a pas regardé une seule seconde
il fascine autant qu'ils font peur
on ne les voit que dans les films ou les
livres
mais on a tendance à oublier que les
tueurs en série existent vraiment
Silvia et Marie-José elle ne
l'oublieront jamais
elles ont connu le pire
elles sont tombées dans les griffes d'un
tueur en série
elles ont réussi à lui échapper mais à
quel prix
comment vit-on après ça
deux femmes au courage impressionnants
deux histoires à peine croyable
je m'appelle Sylvia et j'ai été victime
d'un tueur en série
[Musique]
je m'appelle Marie-Josée Goze je suis
victime d'un tueur en série
un jour Sylvia et Marie-José se sont
retrouvés pris au piège par un tueur en
série
la plupart de celles qui ont croisé la
route de ces criminels ne sont plus là
pour en parler elle on survécu
[Musique]
ce matin Marie-Josée Goz nous emmène
devant la maison de son enfant
nous sommes chez mes parents
je viens mais je peux pas monter
en plus les difficultés mais rien que de
voir ma chambre c'est l'horreur
[Musique]
de mal à revenir dans cette rue c'est
parce qu'elle y a vécu l'enfer
[Musique]
dans la nuit du 9 au 17 septembre 1993
ce jour-là elle se trouve seule dans la
maison
vers 9h du soir
la sonnette
mais qui c'est qui vient me cette heure
aussi
j'ouvre la porte et je me vois Patrick
Tessier devant moi Patrick Tissier un
homme qu'elle avait rencontré quelques
semaines
plus lors d'un dîner chez des amis
[Musique]
avec toi parce que je sais pas quoi
faire et puis je vais te montrer je t'ai
porté la photo de la petite Karine tu
sais que je parle tout le temps
Karine c'est la petite fille de la
nouvelle compagne de Patrick elle a 8
ans
il me montre la photo puis il me dit on
va boire du Coca-Cola ensemble je lui
dis mais moi je ne bois pas de Coca-Cola
ça ne m'intéresse pas
et puis il me force à rentrer je
m'assied
et lui fait le tour de la table
et bien sa copie à côté de moi
et puis me dit tu sais j'ai envie de toi
je suis comment
je dis mais ça va pas
tu repars immédiatement et
je veux plutôt revoir
et ça me va
derrière je suis pas allé fermer la
porte
je me remets à faire mes papiers puis
vers minuit 10 j'étale la télévision
j'ai dit je vais me coucher
arrivé dans ma chambre je sens une
présence
déjà je crie
parce que j'ai réalisé que c'était lui
parce qu'il voulait coucher avec moi
jure
et il m'a dit ça sert à rien
tout est fermé
j'entends
et il m'a jeté contre le lait et ma
sauté dessus
et m'a mis les mains tout autour du cou
il me dit c'est comme ça que tu n'es
qu'une sale
tu es la seule qui me résiste
mais je t'aurais tu partiras comme les
autres Marie José finit par s'écrouler
elle fait une hémorragie cérébrale
et tout d'un coup du sang qui coulait
partout
ça sortait par les yeux par la bouche
par le nez par
et puis là au fur et à mesure je me suis
vidée de mon sang
et
je supportais dans le coma
entre-temps je sais que il m'a violé
mais deux heures plus tard elle sort du
coma
comme je me suis réveillé que j'ai
ouvert les yeux il était là
il était au-dessus de moi il voulait
recommencer j'étais toute ficelée de fil
électrique et de ficelle tout ce qu'il
avait trouvé dans le garage de mes
parents et là j'étais il faut réagir il
faut réagir il a vu que je voulais dire
quelque chose
puis ma défilé le foulard
je lui ai dit
pourquoi tu as fait ça
pourquoi
et là il me dit quand on refuse quelque
chose
un homme on sait jamais comment il va
réagir alors qu'elle fait de son mieux
pour le convaincre d'arrêter son
agresseur change de comportement il sera
adouci j'ai vu au fur et à mesure que je
lui parlais
qui commençait à
baisser de pression et son visage venait
revenir un peu plus normal on aurait dit
qu'il avait plus ses moyens il était
tombé sur une femme plus forte que lui
peut-être pour une vie psychologique
et alors je lui demande tu peux me
détacher et il me répond mais tu sais je
vais partir la seule chose que je te
demande surtout que tu ne parles pas je
lui ai promis que je ne parlerai pas
puis il est parti en effet un départ
inespéré pour Marie-José mais la jeune
femme grièvement blessée est loin d'être
tirée d'affaires elle parvient tout de
même à ramper vers le téléphone pour
appeler les pompiers je disais faut que
je lutte pour que je au moins que je
puisse dire son nom et j'entendais les
pompiers elle nous part elle nous part
elle arrive pas à l'hôpital alors je dis
c'est pas possible
et je vous savais ce que j'ai prié j'ai
dit mon Dieu faites que j'y arrive
faites juste pour ça
le reste après c'était
tant pis je suis foutu tant pis
j'ai tenu
quand je suis arrivé à l'hôpital j'avais
la tête en vrille c'est à dire qu'elle
était tournée ma tête tellement il avait
ses réformes
et j'avais l'autre l'autre truc arrivé à
la hauteur de la
de l'oreille j'avais déjà la police qui
m'attendait
mais seulement je pouvais plus parler
de moins en moins
et il y a un inspecteur de police qui a
dit vous connaissez sûrement
je pouvais le policier épèle chaque
lettre de l'alphabet à Marie-Josée pour
retrouver le nom de son agresseur
Patrick Tissier son nom est déjà connu
des services de police c'est un
récitiviste déjà condamné pour le
meurtre de sa petite amie vingt ans plus
tôt
[Musique]
Stéphane vous êtes criminologue écrivain
et spécialiste des tueurs en série la
question peut paraître simple mais
qu'est-ce qu'un tueur en série
finalement à partir de quand la police
considère quelqu'un comme un tueur en
série
tout d'abord en France la notion de
tueur en série n'existe pas dans le code
pénal donc que vous y étiez une fois
huit fois 15 fois vous pouvez écoper de
la même peine mais selon la définition
du FBI on estime qu'on est un tueur en
série quand on commet au moins trois
meurtres avec un certain intervalle de
temps entre chacun des crimes pourquoi
justement pour différencier des masses
murderer des tueurs de masse style
andersbering Brevik ou James Holmes
comme la turry d'Aurora il y a quelques
mois c'est quoi un mobile psychologique
ça peut être le désir de toute puissance
de contrôle de la victime de l'humilier
ça peut être aussi une connotation
sexuelle
mais ce n'est pas toujours le cas est-ce
qu'on a un portrait robot du tueur en
série plutôt des hommes quel âge quel
milieu
donc 85% des cas dans sur toute la
planète ce sont des hommes et qui
généralement commencent leur premier
crime relativement jeune il ne
deviennent pas tueurs en série du jour
au lendemain ils sont d'abord des
délinquants ordinaires on l'a vu pour
Émile Louis qui avait commis des
escroqueries qui étaient Pyroman si ton
Guy George qu'il a aussi a commis des
agressions sur ses sorts de lait puis
ensuite des vols à caractère fétichiste
des agressions de plus en plus violentes
des viols et ensuite et il a commis ces
meurtres
une course contre la montre commence
alors il faut retrouver l'agresseur
avant qu'il ne sévisse à nouveau
Marie-José elle est passée à deux doigts
de la mort mais les séquelles seront
très lourdes
[Musique]
Silvia a 33 ans depuis deux ans elle
partage une maison avec sa mère Josiane
l'une vit à l'étage et l'autre au
rez-de-chaussée
une promiscuité qui ne doit rien au
hasard
bonjour
ça va
être pour sa fille c'est parce que huit
ans plus tôt elle a failli la perdre
définitivement
tout commence le 20 mai 2004 Sylvia a
alors 25 ans
il était environ midi donc il faisait
chaud et beau ma mère et moi on a décidé
d'aller courir c'était le jour de
l'Ascension tout a commencé et tout
s'est arrêté ce jour-là
j'ai eu un point de côté donc j'ai voulu
ralentir le pas
ma mère et son compagnon d'époque donc
ils m'ont dit bon bah c'est pas grave tu
nous rejoins donc eux ils ont continué à
courir et moi j'ai marché c'est à ce
moment là que
au loin j'ai vu un homme à coudé à une
barrière une rambarde en bois et puis je
vraiment je le trouvais bizarre en fait
au premier abord quoi je me suis dit je
sais pas pourquoi je ressens quelque
chose je veux pas y aller alors j'ai
ralenti mon pas j'ai ralenti et je suis
non je vais faire demi-tour je vais
faire demi-tour et au dernier moment
il fait beau il y a du monde c'est un
parc public il y avait plein d'enfants
partout avec les poussettes les gamins
enfin
des familles entières qui étaient là
j'ai commencé à me dire je délire et
finalement je suis passé quand même j'ai
pas eu le temps de le dépasser que
qui m'a prise et
m'arrêter avec le couteau sous la gorge
une dissertitude si tu cries je te tue
si tu cries je te tue
j'ai crié quand même une première fois
il a serré plus fort et la recommencé à
m'étrangler mais là au point où je ne
pouvais plus du tout sortir de son là il
m'a balancé
il m'a soulevé mais je sais même pas
comment elle a fait il m'a soulevé par
dessus une rambarde et je suis âgée
atterri donc 25 mètres plus bas
un poignet retourné par l'agresseur des
ongles arrachés en tentant de s'échapper
et des ecchymoses dues à la chute Sylvia
est gravement blessé j'avais des
morceaux de bois rentrer dans la chair
j'avais j'avais des brûlures sur des
étendues de peau enfin quand même voilà
sur les bras les jambes les cuisses le
ventre le dos une fois en bas
l'agresseur profite de cet isolement
pour violer sauvagement Sylvia à
plusieurs reprises
je sentais que ce personnage n'était pas
là uniquement pour une agression
sexuelle
qu'il était là aussi pour autre chose et
je l'ai senti dès le départ dès le
départ il avait déjà envie de me tuer
donc je savais que la force ne
marcherait pas donc j'ai tenté autre
chose j'ai tenté ensuite de parler avec
lui en fait
j'ai parlé presque deux heures quand
même avec lui entre bien sûr entre les
actes sexuels qui faisaient subir et pas
gentiment donc
c'était vraiment pas évident mais je
voulais juste m'en sortir
deux heures au cours desquelles la jeune
femme fait preuve d'un incroyable
instinct de survie
je contrôlais tout je contrôlais ma voix
je contrôle et mes tremblements je
contrôlais mon regard les mots ma façon
de parler pour lui faire comprendre que
bah ça me faisait rien que me faisait
rien qui me faisait pas peur que j'avais
pas mal je vais simplement dit aussi
mais pourquoi tu as fait ça alors que tu
pourrais simplement m'inviter à boire un
café et je t'aurais surement dit oui
parce que voilà t'es pas moche voilà
pourquoi pas moi aussi je suis
célibataire tu m'aurais invité à boire
un café ça aurait été plus simple
et là il s'est retrouvé à se dire bah
oui finalement peut-être et du coup ah
bon mais je suis mignon enfin il m'a dit
un truc comme ça et c'est là je dis bon
bah je vais parler avec lui comme ça
je dis bah oui voilà des beaux yeux
enfin n'importe quoi enfin ce que tout
ce qui me passait par la tête alors
c'était un horrible monstre
[Musique]
alors que Sylvia tente de survivre aux
assauts de son agresseur elle distingue
au loin la vie qui continue alors
qu'elle est en plein cauchemar
j'entendais les enfants jouer au tennis
parce qu'il y avait un cours de tennis
pas loin
et là je me disais mais
on est juste à côté ils savent pas que
là il y a quelqu'un qui est en danger
j'ai aussi entendu ma mère m'appeler
j'ai entendu son compagnon de l'époque
donc m'appelait
ça c'est encore pire que tout ils sont
en haut il m'appelle et je peux pas
répondre
Josiane la mère de Sylvia a compris
qu'il lui était arrivé quelque chose
elle se lance donc à sa recherche
quoi qu'il se passe je savais que si
j'étais en haut je pourrais reprendre le
dessus
donc je voulais sortir pour pouvoir
reprendre le dessus au bout de quelques
temps je vais quand même dire quand même
il faudrait peut-être que tu viennes
avec moi
que tu m'aides à nettoyer mes blessures
parce que là quand même ça peut pas
rester comme ça
confiant l'agresseur qui pense que
Sylvia est seul ce jour-là accepte de
l'emmener nettoyer ses blessures
j'ai réussi à remonter donc avec lui
évidemment il m'a pas lâché comme ça il
m'a serré très fort contre le contre lui
et j'ai continué le juge jusqu'au bout
donc je lui ai pris je l'ai pris par la
taille et j'ai comme ça je vais bien
montrer que j'allais pas m'échapper que
j'étais à lui et que j'allais pas partir
comme ça qui pouvait avoir confiance etc
pendant ce temps après avoir fait
plusieurs fois le tour du parc la mère
de Sylvia panique et appelle la police
mais au loin Josiane voit enfin revenir
sa fille elle court à sa rencontre
l'agresseur ne s'y attend pas
la voir arriver avec un mec énorme grand
balèze
collé contre elle mais collé-serré
je me dis mais
avec une voix de petite fille très aiguë
très bizarre
et elle me dit le monsieur m'a sauvé ma
mère qui me dit là là où tu étais
qu'est-ce qui se passe t'étais ouf enfin
qui n'a pas vu non plus mon état qui
avait les yeux tellement rempli de
l'arme de toute façon elle voyait plus
rien et je lui dis mais tu trouves pas
compte j'ai appelé la police moi j'ai
cru qu'il t'était arrivé quelque chose
très vite l'agresseur comprend que la
situation vient de basculer en sa
défaveur il perd alors ses moyens
et là je me suis détachée en une seconde
j'ai couru j'ai poussé ma mère loin mais
je l'ai poussé violemment parce que
j'avais peur qu'il s'attaque à elle et
qui lui se prenne qu'elle se prenne un
coup de couteau et là lui il est parti
direct et moi j'ai couru direct dans la
cabane des gardiens
et là j'étais complètement là j'ai tout
lâché quoi c'était
la police arrive sur place et se lance
alors à sa poursuite
ils l'ont arrêté juste quand ils
mettaient la clé dans sa serrure quoi
donc il partait il allait partir
donc juste attends l'homme qu'ils
viennent d'arrêter s'appelle Alain Penin
il a 33 ans à l'époque il est encore
inconnu des services de police
malheureusement son parcours de
criminels sexuel ne va pas s'arrêter là
alors on vient de le voir Sylvia a
réussi à maîtriser d'une certaine façon
manipulée son agresseur est-ce que c'est
un coup de chance
disons que c'est extrêmement rare parce
que lorsque vous êtes entre les mains
d'un tueur en série vous avez quasiment
aucune chance d'en échapper la seule
petite chance c'est justement elle a
réussi à toucher la fibre de l'homme qui
se cachait derrière ce monstre est-ce
qu'on sait ce qu'ils ont dans la tête au
moment de leur crime au moment où ils
vont commettre leur crime ils savent
déjà ce qu'ils vont faire parce que
c'est un fantasme qui mûrit chez eux
depuis très longtemps
fantasme peut être sexuel peut se
manifester aussi par des actes de
bondage le fait de ligoter la victime du
certaine manière de la mettre dans une
posture humiliante dégradante tout ça
c'est des fantasmes qu'ils ont
généralement au moment de l'adolescence
et la plupart du temps les premiers
crimes d'un tueur en série sont commis
vers une vingtaine d'années lorsque vous
arrêtez par exemple à Michel Fourniret
qui a 62 ans ça veut dire qu'elle a il a
plusieurs décennies de crimes derrière
lui
pour l'heure Sylvia et saine et sauve
mais cette agression aura des
conséquences dramatiques sur le reste de
sa vie
[Musique]
alors qu'elle a survécu une extrémie à
son agression Marie-José est conduite à
l'hôpital elle y restera pendant trois
jours à son chevet les policiers tentent
d'en savoir un peu plus le lundi
en fin de Prométhée l'inspecteur de
police qui était à côté de moi qui
m'interrogeait aussi reçoit un coup de
téléphone
et puis je le vois oh là là j'ai changé
de tête il me dit
nous avons un autre cas
disparition d'une petite fille
je vous assure j'aurais cru que mon
corps il se retournait dans tous les
sens je pensais vraiment à Carine
c'est la petite fille sur la photo que
Patrick Tissier lui avait montré c'était
sûr c'était son tonton chéri
elle appelait comme ça
arrivait à Perpignan quelques mois plus
tôt Patrick Tissier passait beaucoup de
temps avec sa compagne et les deux
enfants de celle-ci
après vérification les policiers
confirment l'intuition de Marie-José
c'est bien la petite Karine qui a
disparu
bande de suite ils se sont mis à
l'assaut comme ils appellent
et puis il a été retrouvé que
huit jours après
les efforts de Marie-José pour
collaborer avec la police ont permis
l'arrestation de Patrick Tissier mais il
est déjà trop tard cela n'aura pas été
suffisant pour pouvoir sauver la petite
Karine elle a été violée et assassinée
[Musique]
cinq ans d'instructions seront
nécessaires pour retracer le parcours de
Patrick Tissier
alors qu'il a déjà purgé deux peines de
prison il est libéré en janvier 92
après l'agression de Marie-José et le
meurtre de la petite Karine il fait une
troisième victime Conchita
en 1998 le procès de Patrick Tissier
fait la une des médias
[Musique]
Marie-Josée Goze l'unique témoin vivant
de l'extrême violence de Patrick Tissier
s'avance doucement vers la barre
personne ne voulait que j'aille au
tribunal aucun médecin ne souhaitait que
je parle à la barre et ça va être trop
peur que je me forme
et puis petit à petit je dis faut quand
même que j'y aille parce qu'autrement sa
portera pas les fruits de la même façon
ce procès sera tout de même l'occasion
pour Marie-José d'être enfin confronté à
son agresseur
je l'ai regardé droit dans les yeux
et je lui ai dit ce que j'avais à lui
dire
que c'était un [__] il a baissé les
yeux et un moment donné je lui dis mais
t'as pas honte de baisser les yeux
[Musique]
je lui ai dit mais regarde-moi en face
moi je te regarde il se met à me faire
ses excuses je lui dis ta parole de
faire des excuses
et ben moi je les accepte pas tes
excuses
et si on t'enferme je serai la plus
heureuse du monde il y en a d'autres qui
seront et ça c'est terminé comme
ça à l'issue du procès Patrick Tissier
est condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité assortie d'une peine de
sûreté de 30 ans
il y en a qui
mais j'ai les largement
[Musique]
vous êtes avocat alors justement les
victimes se plaignent souvent de ne pas
avoir la parole est-ce que le moment de
ce procès c'est juste le moment pour eux
de pouvoir raconter leurs histoires se
libérer
l'occasion la cour d'assise il faut que
pour les là où les victimes survivantes
ou leur famille si elles sont décédées
ça soit un temps d'expression
c'est-à-dire d'expliquer ce qui s'est
passé et puis surtout le ressenti le
ressenti et puis la situation actuelle
leur construction ou la descente aux
enfers ou la construction partielle et
puis ça doit être aussi un temps de
compréhension d'écoute et de
compréhension je dis pas de pardon de
compréhension
des parties civils à l'égard de la
personne accusée ou de sa famille pour
bien comprendre aussi comment ce qui
s'est produit même si c'est
impardonnable après c'est un problème de
religion et de morale mais de comprendre
comment ça a pu se produire et qui est
le la personne qui a agressé qui a violé
qui a tué voilà je crois que c'est
important parce que souvent les victimes
viennent leurs avocats vous disent à la
fin de procès d'assise ça leur a fait du
bien d'entendre un certain nombre de
choses ça leur a fait du bien d'entendre
des parents de l'assassin ça leur a fait
du bien il y a des choses qui n'avaient
pas compris qu'ils ont été pas venu à
l'esprit et c'est bien que lors de ta
plaque plaidoirie tu les dis parce que
ça n'efface pas leur malheur mais enfin
il y a des choses où ça cadre quand on
comprend les choses
[Musique]
son bourreau est désormais sous les
verrous mais le calvaire de Marie-Josée
ne s'est pas arrêté pour autant elle
doit vivre avec de multiples séquelles
physiques
[Musique]
après son agression Sylvia se retrouve à
l'idée pendant plusieurs semaines livré
à elle-même elle sombre dans la
dépression
l'hôpital la morphine les blessures
l'état psychologique où on en parle même
plus quoi de toute façon j'étais pas
moi-même donc je faisais des crises je
tapais dans les murs
dans la rue
je pouvais je pouvais voilà je pouvais
me montrer très violente c'était très
douloureux parce que on est impuissant
on peut être là et l'aider l'épauler
parler avec elle faire ce qu'il faut
pour trouver l'avocat pour trouver les
psy d'essayer de parler d'autre chose
d'essayer même des fois de rire pour
pour lui faire voir que la vie continue
même si on en a pas envie ni l'une ni
l'autre mais en fait c'est un combat
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps comme on fait si on est tout seul
bon bah on crève on crève parce que moi
je me suis j'ai tenté de me suicider
quand même trois fois voilà
si j'avais pas été aidé je serai plus là
aujourd'hui
petit à petit Sylvia se reconstruit avec
l'aide de sa mère mais deux ans plus
tard au moment du procès elle doit à
nouveau faire face à son agresseur je
suis arrivé à la barre j'ai pleuré tout
de suite
et je me suis raciste j'ai recommencé et
j'ai repéré j'ai pas pu parler je me
suis rassise et m'ont rappelé une
troisième fois et là je fais c'est bon
je vais y aller et je vais arriver je
l'ai regardé je l'ai pas quitté des yeux
je lui en sais presque un défi
du genre que c'est moi qui t'ai eu c'est
pas le contraire
et il m'a pas regardé une seule seconde
pas une seule seconde Sylvia réussit
finalement à raconter son agression à la
barre à l'issue du procès le verdict
tombe Alain Penin est condamné à 10 ans
d'emprisonnement pour moi 10 ans c'était
rien du tout tout le monde m'a dit mais
10 ans mais 10 ans tu te rends pas
compte c'est génial disant tu te rends
pas compte c'est super alors c'est super
bah alors super si c'est super alors
super
Alain pena dort désormais en prison de
son côté Sylvia conserve des
traumatismes importants des séquelles
qui l'handicap au quotidien
même souvent handicapé comment handicapé
par certaines angoisses ou
des peurs des choses qui sont vraiment
plus fortes que moi c'est-à-dire par
exemple je peux pas prendre les
transports je peux pas me promener tard
le soir toute seule enfin voilà même par
exemple c'est vrai que j'ai eu des
opportunités de travail magnifique que
j'ai dû refuser parce que parce qu'il
fallait prendre les transports je ne
pouvais pas y aller en voiture j'ai eu
très peur quand je me suis retrouvé sur
le quai donc du coup j'ai arrêté et une
autre aussi opportunité il fallait faire
aussi du porte-à-porte et me retrouver
chez les gens ça je pouvais pas le
supporter donc c'est c'est des angoisses
c'est plus fort que moi
des troubles psychologiques mais aussi
d'importantes c'est qu'elle physique
[Musique]
inspirer souffler
voilà ça se depuis de nombreuses années
elle doit se rendre régulièrement chez
son psychologue son kinésithérapeute ou
son ostéopathe physique moi que je
retrouve sur Sylvia enfin du moins que
j'ai retrouvé lorsqu'il est venu pour la
première fois au cabinet c'était
principalement un bassin complètement
bloqué
des lombaires en souffrance des
cervicales pas toutes les dorsales au
bout de quelques temps tout ça se bloque
se refaire et puis elle peut plus
marcher correctement
évaluer et évoluer par nos normalement
et ça la restreint dans sa mobilité dans
sa vie de tous les jours quoi clairement
Sylvia est donc dans l'obligation de se
rendre chaque semaine à ces séances
et ça coûte cher parce que la mutuelle
est rembourse donc que trois fois par an
et puis tout ça ce n'est pas pris en
compte donc
je galère oui financièrement avec tout
ça aussi c'est un peu perte de temps
perte d'argent et se dire qu'on est pas
infirme mais qu'on est obligé d'y aller
donc forcément c'est que ça va pas quoi
des opportunités professionnelles
gâchées des heures passées chez les
médecins de nombreux problèmes
financiers la vie de Sylvia la ramène
constamment à son agression
vous êtes psychanalyste comment se
remet-on d'une épreuve pareille
est-ce qu'on peut s'en remettre
complètement déjà il y a laissé qu'elle
physique on le voit très très
douloureusement et puis et puis il y a
les séquelles psychologiques je crois
que c'est un travail de reconstruction
de soi absolument énorme il faut
comprendre que l'agression elle est
arrivée d'abord c'est un traumatisme
c'est-à-dire que c'est quelque chose à
quoi en aucun cas on ne pouvait
s'attendre ce qui veut dire que
psychologiquement on ne pouvait en aucun
cas il y être préparé puisque c'était
quelque chose hors de la pensée comme
une on n'était pas armés or notre
psychisme il est fait comme comme un
compteur électrique pour supporter une
certaine charge d'électricité si vous
branchez un truc qui est un générateur
qui demande énormément d'électricité ou
je sais pas quoi ça va tout faire
exploser et quels sont les séquelles les
plus fréquentes
on n'arrive pas à vivre à le dit très
bien elle a beaucoup de mal à vivre elle
a peur elle a peur dehors c'est à dire
que l'extérieur ne vient quelque chose
angoissant elle peut pas prendre le
métro il y a des conséquences évidemment
pour une femme comme pour un homme sur
la vie sexuelle pour une femme en termes
de peur pour un homme ça va pouvoir
donner de la puissance enfin il y a tout
ce qui fait que tout d'un coup si vous
voulez le traumatisme c'est ça c'est
qu'une on est dans la vie normale et
tout d'un coup vous arrive quelque chose
qui normalement n'arrive que dans les
cauchemars sauf que là c'était pas un
cauchemar c'était pour de vrai
[Musique]
6 ans après son agression alors que
Sylvia commence à peine à aller mieux et
qu'elle pense enfin tourner
définitivement la page Alain pena va
encore frapper
bonne journée merci au revoir au revoir
[Musique]
après la condamnation de Patrick Tissier
Marie-Josée Goze et soulagée mais pas
pour autant guérir elle vit depuis 19
ans avec une Minerve et des béquilles
elle souffre également de graves
problèmes respiratoires
depuis mon agression
et c'est quel physique c'est toutes mes
vertèbres cervicales et ma colonne
vertébrale qui est écrasée ce qui veut
dire que je suis limitée à beaucoup de
mouvements
Éric coucou à tout moment il peut
m'arriver quelque chose
et ça il faut vivre avec
aujourd'hui elle rejoint son ami Eric
ensemble ils ont créé une association
pour les enfants maltraités
32 ans qu'on se connaît
c'est vrai que on a passé du temps
ensemble on a passé du bon temps et du
mauvais temps
Eric c'est la première personne que
Marie-José a appelé après son agression
j'arrive à l'hôpital et je constate que
Marie est totalement défigurée le visage
entièrement noir tu méfier même pas
envoyé la couleur des yeux on voyait
absolument rien j'ai eu un geste de
recul j'ai failli tomber dans l'épaule
tu te souviens j'ai été sur une chaise
parce que j'étais et je voulais vraiment
pas te montrer à quel point j'étais ta
tête elle disait tout voilà marie est
une personne qui a vraiment
rebondi qui a
usé de résilience qui a fait vraiment
tout ce qu'il faut et qui a gardé son
sourire et qui a gardé l'estime et
l'amitié de toutes les personnes qui
l'entourent bon voilà
je te dis un grand bravo
du conseil d'administration qui a été
qui a été
chez les amis qui ont toujours été là
et ils m'ont remonte et ils m'ont fait
sortir
ils m'ont emmené à droite et à gauche
pour que je j'essaye d'oublier un tas de
choses
et bonjour
du drame qui a touché Marie José et même
né une amitié
René est l'un des premiers policiers à
avoir interrogé le jour de son agression
il m'a pris la main il me parlait
gentiment et essayer de me réconforter
parce que j'avais tellement de
difficultés
et puis ça m'a marqué moi le flic est la
victime il y a des liens qui se créent
on en parle là j'en ai parlé à mon
épouse j'ai dit tu te rends compte j'ai
vu une dame comme ça comme ça comme ça
et
ça marque mais ce ne sont que des années
après les faits qu'ils vont se recroiser
ils vont aussitôt se reconnaître aussi
regarder et je lui ai dit mais on se
connaît elle m'a répondu je crois oui
oui
et moi on n'a pas trop traîné quand même
elle me dit vous êtes René boisé
jeudi Marie-Jo c'est pas vrai
se jeter dans les bras tous les deux et
depuis c'est une amitié qui dure
[Musique]
Frédéric Malon vous êtes commissaire de
visionnaire vous dirigez le crvp
l'Office central de la répression des
violences aux personnes est-ce que
enquêter sur un tueur en série c'est
quelque chose de particulier
c'est forcément quelque chose de
particulier
déjà des tueurs en série il y en a pas à
tous les coins de rue en France
heureusement il y en a donc une minorité
et lorsqu'ils sont détectés en tout cas
pour les enquêteurs ça devient des
enquêtes prioritaires évidemment puisque
ce sont des enquêtes on sait que
l'individu peut commettre de nouvelles
victimes pour nous donc c'est une
pression supplémentaire c'est un
challenge supplémentaire pour d'une part
l'identifier si l'indivine n'est pas
identifié et si identifier le localiser
et l'arrêter le plus vite possible
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes
mobilisées est-ce que ça prend du temps
la première chose à faire c'est quand
même savoir qu'on a à faire à tueur en
série on peut avoir un meurtre un
deuxième meurtre un troisième meurtre il
y a pas forcément de lien entre eux vous
prenez des gens comme comme Michel
Fourniret par exemple
il a sévit
dans les Ardennes il a servi en Belgique
il a sévit dans la région d'Auxerre au
départ c'est pas évident de relier
toutes ces voilà les unes entre elles
simplement parce que le type de victimes
n'est pas forcément le même parfois des
enfants et parfois des personnes adultes
le mode opératoire n'est pas forcément
le même mais parfois l'usage d'armes à
feu parfois l'usage d'arme blanche
parfois les strangulation et vous avez
un logiciel pour vous aider à cela le
SALVAC alors SALVAC c'est effectivement
un outil informatique qui était
introduit en France en 2003 et c'est un
outil qui a vocation à faire des
rapprochements à faire c'est un outil
donc qui est alimenté à la fois par les
services de police et de gendarmerie de
toute la France donc de part toute
l'information qui converge vers ce
service cette information est analysée
vraiment dans le détail il y a des
questionnaires qui sont quand même
très très pointues quel type
d'information
évidemment porte sur les éléments
objectifs d'un dossier que ce soit sur
le mode opératoire sur l'auteur sur la
scène de crime mais après sur des
aspects beaucoup plus liés à ce qu'on
appelle l'analyse comportementale c'est
à dire non seulement ce que l'auteur a
fait mais aussi ce qu'il a peut-être
voulu faire mais qu'il a pas pu faire
parce qu'il a pu être empêché parce que
la victime a résisté un peu plus on peut
avoir donc des faits qui ne sont pas on
va dire des copier-coller en termes de
mode opératoire mais qu'on peut
rapprocher en tenant compte justement de
la psychologie de l'auteur
et en faisant une analyse vraiment de
son comportement
[Musique]
l'agresseur de Silvia est incarcérée
depuis son arrestation en mai 2004 mais
alors qu'il a écopé de 10 ans en 2009 il
sort en liberté conditionnelle après
avoir passé cinq ans en prison
à ce moment-là
forcément j'ai paniqué j'appelle mon
avocat etc c'est quoi ce soir je l'a pas
fait ses 10 ans aussi si il sort enfin
bref donc là je j'ai dit ok bon bah il
faut que je parte là
Sylvia déménage en catastrophe et va
s'installer au-dessus de l'appartement
de sa mère elle n'a désormais plus
qu'une seule crainte car la pena
récidive comme ça j'ai un coup de fil
donc je réponds et on me dit oui bonjour
vous êtes bien Sylvia oui
je suis journaliste Intel ok vous êtes
bien la victime de Intel je ne dirais
jamais son nom j'ai fait oui est-ce que
vous êtes au courant non
il a recommencé sauf que cette fois est
la tuer
Alain pena l'agresseur de Sylvia est
suspectée d'avoir violé et assassiné
Natacha une jeune femme de 29 ans qui
courait dans une forêt du Nord de la
France et là à ce moment là tout est
reparti
tout ce dont j'avais essayé de
travailler jusqu'à maintenant toutes mes
phobies toutes mes séquelles tout si
tout ça c'est revenu
6 ans après l'agression de Silvia
l'homme a utilisé exactement le même
mode opératoire il a utilisé les mêmes
armes et
il a fait la même chose donc je
indirectement je
sais exactement ce qu'elle a pu vivre ce
qu'elle a pu ressentir et la douleur
qu'elle a pu endurer j'ai même pu
imaginer
s'écrit j'ai même pu imaginer dessus
tout s'imaginer fin sauf que moi je peux
plus que l'imaginer donc c'est encore
pire c'est savoir ce que la ressenti
c'est c'est comme si c'était moi qui
l'avais tué parce que à la base c'est ça
qui voulait faire puisque c'était son
truc à lui
[Musique]
je pense que voilà la mort de Natacha
aurait pu être évité j'ai toujours dit
qu'il recommencerait j'ai toujours dit
que son truc c'était de tuer
[Musique]
la jeune femme a le sentiment de n'avoir
pas été écouté par la justice le procès
pour le meurtre de Natacha va bientôt
débuter Sylvia il voit la chance d'être
enfin entendu quoi qu'il arrive je serai
présente quoi que je fasse où je sois je
serai là pour tout pour soutenir la
famille et voilà et pour Natacha parce
qu'elle elle peut pas se défendre
dira tout ce que Natacha peux pas dire
j'ai hâte que ce jour arrive moi moi
j'ai vraiment hâte que le procès arrive
mais en même temps ça fait un petit peu
peur de mettre quelqu'un en prison
sachant qu'il va encore ressortir et qui
va encore recommencer et qui sera
surtout pas assez vieux pour voilà pour
s'arrêter de faire quoi que ce soit
aujourd'hui en mémoire de Natacha et
pour éviter que ce genre de drame ne
recommence Silvia veut faire évoluer la
législation sur la récidive
une fois que je réussis à obtenir cette
loi oui je vais prendre tout ça voilà
tous les DVD tout ça je vais tout
prendre et je vais faire un grand feu de
joie voilà avec et là je tournerai pas
une page là je tendrai on va dire je
vais recommencer une nouvelle vie voilà
[Musique]
le chemin pour y arriver est encore long
mais Sylvia est déterminé
et pour faire avancer les choses elle
écrit d'ailleurs en ce moment un livre
sur son histoire
ce sont des gens qui vont forcément
sortir un jour est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on devrait faire comme la Norvège et
ne les laisser sortir que si on estime
qu'ils ne sont plus dangereux
je milite au sein d'une association de
victimes qui s'appelait victime en série
dont je suis un des membres fondateurs
et nous militons notamment pour quelque
chose qui fait quelquefois sourire mais
ce serait le cumul des peines parce
qu'en France vous écopez de la même
peine quand vous tuez une fois où vous
tuez 5 10 15 fois et un pays comme par
exemple l'Afrique du Sud ou certains
États américains vous avez des tueurs
qui peuvent écoper de 1200 années de
prison donc à partir de là même s'ils
font preuve de bonne conduite
on est sûr qu'il ne récidiveront pas
parce que la récidive est quasiment
assurée pour les tueurs en série sont
des psychopathes aucun psychiatre
psychologue ne peut entre guillemets
guérir les fantasmes d'un tueur en série
il y a aussi
un système qui a été mis en place par
exemple en Suisse en Autriche et au
Québec qui fonctionne très bien c'est
lorsqu'un individu est jugé dangereux il
ne sort pas de prison même lorsqu'il a
purgé sa peine est-ce qu'on a des
contre-exemples de tueur en série qui
n'ont pas récidivé il y a sûrement des
exceptions de tueur en série qui ont pu
être libérés par le passé mais qui n'ont
pas récidivé j'en connais pas mais ça
existe obligatoirement mais en règle
générale
ils n'ont aucune envie de s'arrêter de
commettre leur crime même lorsqu'ils ont
atteint un âge avancé parce que ça ne se
passe pas sous la ceinture les fantasmes
sexuels sont justement des fantasmes et
ils n'ont pas envie d'y renoncer
[Musique]
malgré ses souffrances physiques et son
état de santé fragile Marie José ne se
laisse pas aller
au plus rien faire maintenant je
m'occupe parce qu'il faut que je voye
les gens j'en ai besoin de rencontrer du
monde et après quand ça sera sec on fera
les traits noirs puisque le cœur est
noir les associations
sortir aussi parce que même comme je
n'ai pas envie et ben j'y vais et quand
je reviens le soir j'ai passé une
après-midi extraordinaire
Marie-José a fait les Beaux-Arts alors
aujourd'hui elle transmet son savoir aux
autres
quand je suis là je
suis à côté d'elle il y a beaucoup de
d'ateliers différents donc il faut que
ma tête elle fonctionne pour chaque
atelier je pense plus à rien on a une
directrice formidable parce que elle est
à l'écoute de tout le monde et même
quand ça va pas c'est elle qui nous
remonte le moral ça m'est arrivé il y a
six ans quand je suis rentrée au club
c'est vrai ou pas
et Marie-Jo m'a remonté on passait plus
de temps à parler mais malgré ses amis
et malgré ses activités l'état de santé
de Marie-José se dégrade
dernièrement elle a dû passer plusieurs
semaines à l'hôpital pour elle chaque
jour est un combat pour la vie
Marie-José a conscience d'être une
miraculée la folie de son agresseur aura
eu raison de deux autres femmes et d'une
petite fille
l'horreur de ses actes est certaines
failles judiciaires dans ce genre de cas
on conduit le Garde des Sceaux de
l'époque a créé une loi dite de
perpétuité incompressible
la peine incompressible c'est 30 ans
maximum mais pendant 30 ans et il ne
peut pas demander de sortir de prison ce
qui a été
voté après tout ça c'est que
maintenant c'est fait une demande de
sortie il faut qu'il repasse devant le
tribunal et là je dois si je suis
toujours en vie je dois être présente
recommencer redire les choses pour que
bon ça sera d'autres jurés et il faut
qu'il comprenne bien la situation
[Musique]
en attendant de connaître l'issue du
procès de l'impunat Silvia continue
d'essayer de se reconstruire
[Musique]
l'équitation pour moi c'est ça m'a sauvé
la vie
quand je suis au contact des chevaux ça
tout de suite ça m'apaise
si jamais je vois que ça marche pas lui
et moi j'ai tout de suite il faut que je
fasse attention que je fasse un travail
sur moi-même que je me calme et que
voilà et du coup ça des fois je pleure
un bon coup
quand je vois que ça va pas je pleure un
bon coup et je reviens et ça va mieux
grâce à l'équitation Silvia reprend
petit à petit confiance en elle
depuis l'enfance elle a aussi une autre
passion la danse
en particulier la danse orientale un
éloge à la sensualité
obtenue de son passif cette activité
constitue un vrai défi par rapport à mon
agression aussi je voulais pas que que
qui gagne à ce niveau là c'est à dire
que qui me retire cette passion par
rapport au fait que je dois me montrer
je dois montrer mon corps etc et ben non
c'est et je veux pas je voulais pas
qu'il gagne tout simplement je voulais
pas qu'il prenne le dessus là dessus et
qui me retire ma passion parce que
effectivement au début j'ai eu beaucoup
de mal à danser et non c'était hors de
question qui gagne là-dessus non
mais Sylvia est une battante aujourd'hui
elle a vaincu ses peurs elle est devenue
danseuse professionnelle ce soir elle se
produit dans un restaurant oriental
c'est vrai que la danse ça me permet
aussi de
m'extérioriser en fait de tenir et
d'avancer c'est ce qui me permet
d'exister
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait du bien ça fait plaisir et
c'est un bien-être voilà ce que c'est
après on dort bien on évite de faire des
cauchemars
[Musique]
malgré leurs efforts pour oublier
Sylvia et Marie-José garderont à jamais
en elle le traumatisme de leur face à
face avec leurs agresseurs ce monstre
excusez-moi on ne le soignera jamais
et il va recommencer ça j'en suis
certaine il a ça dans la peau il peut
pas s'en passer alors il recommence
j'ai retrouvé
quelques joie de vivre et quelques bons
moments et quelques envies mais c'est
pas voilà on échangeait à jamais c'est
pas faut pas rêver